if you were looking forward to exploring
the switches Virtual Console on launch
day then I've got some disappointing
news I'm Tony this is a game spot news
update and if you want to know as soon
as the Virtual Console does go live be
sure to subscribe nintendo released a
statement saying the virtual console
will not be available day one on switch
but the company will share more
information in the future the same goes
for streaming services like Netflix or
YouTube which may also come later note
that this is separate from the eShop
which will offer recent downloadable
titles like shovel Knight and breadth of
the wild on launch day and here's some
more good news linking your Nintendo
network ID and Nintendo account will let
you share funds across other Nintendo
devices the Nintendo switch hit store
shelves on Friday March third we'll have
plenty of coverage leading up to and on
launch day and you can check out our 12
switch live stream on gamespot right now
to keep up with all the latest from
Nintendo you're already in the right
place